كريم بنزيما هذا هو حديث الساعه رايح
الاتحاد مو رايح الاتحاد رح يلبس الاصفر
والاسود والوان العميد ولا بعد طيب كريم
زي ما يودع ريال مدريد بعد اربعه عشره
عامه بعد 14 عاما قضاها بين صفوف الملكه
طبعا في بيان اعلان رح
يله
مهاجمه الذي حمل الفريق على اكتافه بعد
رحيل رونالدو عام 2018 يغادر بعد تحقيق
كافه الالقاب الممكنه 25 لقبا فاز بها
بنزيما محققا رقما قياسيا بالتساوي مع
مارسيلو مارسيلو
ومارسيلو
اذا كاكثر اللاعبين تتويجا بالبطولات مع
الميرنغه اهمها طبعا خمسه القاب بمسابقه
دوري ابطال اوروبا التقرير تشير الى ان
السعوديه هي الوجهه وجهه بنزيما المقبله
والاتحاد السعودي توصل بالفعل الى اتفاق
معه وهي مساله وقت قبل الاعلان الرسمي
هكذا تقول الانباء على كل حال عام 2009
يوقع ريال مدريد مع المهاجم الفرنسي كريم
بنزيما صاحب 21 عاما انذاك مقابل
35 مليون يورو وكان قادما من ليون لينضم
وقتها بعد الاعلان عن صفقه كريستيانو
رونالدو الخياليه بثلاثه ايام فقط خلال
فترتهم مع مدريد حقق كريم بنزيما 25 بطوله
بما في ذلك اربعه القاب في الدوري
الاسباني خمسه القاب دوري ابطال اوروبا هو
ثاني افضل هدافي مدريد على الاطلاق
مشاهدينا بعد رونالدو سجل هدفا في ظهوره
الاخير امس و353 هدفا اخرين في 648 مباراه
خاضها بقميص الفريق لكنه الافضل عندما
يتعلق الامر بالتمريرات الحاسمه برصيد 165
تمريره كريم بنزيما وصل الى قمه اداء
واعطائه في الموسم الاحترافي الثامن عشر
له في الملاعب وحققه جائزه افضل لاعب في
العالم
خلال
العام الماضي بعدما سجل 24
هدفا في جميع المسابقات
[موسيقى]
في الاستوديو ينضم الينا الصحفي الرياضي
محمد حامد
رونالدو قلت رايح وقلت المبلغ تمام ميسي
وانت رايح ولسه شبه مؤكد بنزيما رايح ولا
مش رايح
خلاص بس ما فيش عقد في جيب المره دي بس
اقدر اقول ان الصفقه خلاص تمت طبعا حصل
تاخير يومين ثلاثه في الفتره دي كما تقول
الصحافه من ريال مدريد ان بيريز كان بيبحث
عن البديل وخلينا نقول ان بنزيما من اوفى
الاوفياء سريال مدريد وفي نقطه كمان ربما
البعض لا يعلمها ان بيريز يعشق هذا اللاعب
تحديدا في تاريخ ريال مدريد وفي تاريخ
اداره بيريز بالمناسبه بيريز يساوي رؤساء
الدول في مكانته يعني اللاعب الوحيد اللي
ذهاب له للبيت لليوم في فرنسا ليتفاوض
معاها هو كريم بنزيما بنزين ابدا لم
يفعلها اي لاعب وضل طوال مسيره كريم
بنزيما يدعمه بشكل غير عادي طوال الوقت
حتى في الوقت اللي كان
ضده وفرنسا ومشكله المنتخب وكذا كان دايما
داعم لكريم بنزيما
طيب استاذ محمد ما الذي تتوقعه او ما هو
الشيء الذي سيقدمه بنزيما في حال تاكد
ظهور ذهابه الى الاتحاد لنادي الاتحاد
وايضا ما الذي سيقدم للدوري السعودي بعد
رونالدو صحيح اصبحت المعادله هي يعني
خلينا نقول خلال ايام تكتمل رونالدو مع
الهلال وميسي
رونالدو النصر مع النصر
اعتقد عايزين ميسي كمان
وميسي طبعا
وكريم بنزيما مع الاتحاد اكبر ثلاث انديه
واعتقد الكره العالميه ستبقى ستكون في
السعوديه يعني بعد ذلك
ماذا سيقدم انا ظني انه هو عمره 35 ولكن
لا زال فت جدا وهداف يعني هداف بالمعنى
الحرفي لكلمه هداف يستطيع انه يخلص الكثير
من المباريات وكما قلنا من قبل نجوم بهذا
الوزن نقوم بهذه الشعبيه يتجاوز وجودهم
مساله كره القدم
ومساله تسويقيه في ملف
للسعوديه لكاس العالم يعني كما نقول يعني
لم لم يصبح حقيقه سيكون السفراء هو لكن في
الطريق سيكونوا سفراء له ونقطه ثانيه معلش
اسمحي لي مهم جدا المجتمع السعودي ثلثينه
شباب مجتمع شاب و90
هؤلاء الشباب يعشقون كره القدم فلماذا لا
نلبي لهم حاجتهم النجوم العالمين اللي كان
اللي كانوا فقط
على الارض نعم فيها جانب نفسي كمان بكسر
حاجز مع العالميه السعودي
يعني اهم بطوله كرويه في العالم لا نستطيع
الا ان نتابعها
بانه كريم بنزيما الى الاتحاد ان شاء الله
هزرت في الطريق بعض الاشاعات من الممكن
انه في كلام عن راموس وراموس هازارد
يعني انا انا قاعد اقول هذا الكلام لكن
اليوم كريم بنزيما هل سيكون على مفارقه في
كل هؤلاء النجوم رونالدو ولا راح يصير هذه
المنافسه فهمني
ابدا لاستطيع اي خبير كروي حتى في العالم
ان يتوقع ماذا سيفعل لاعب في بيئه مختلفه
تماما خلينا نتكلم بواقعيه ولكن انا ظني
وتوقعي ان كريم بنزيما
لان كريم بنزيما كالسي قريب لينا تعقيبه
تركيبه قريبه علينا يعني كان دايما يجي في
المنطقه وبالمناسبه الكويت حتى حتى لو
خارج السياق كانت من البلدان السباقه انها
تستقطب نجوم على اليمين في الدورات
الرمضانيه يعني ميسي ظهر بالبشت قبل كده
في الكويت
فالفكره ببساطه ان هؤلاء النجوم قدموا
كثيرا للمنطقه عارفين معرفه ما بثقافه
المنطقه خاصه كريم بنزيما لاسباب عقائديه
واسباب تعود الى اصوله
مثل مصري يا خبر النهارده بفلوس بكره
هيبقى ببلاش خلاص قال لك هو الخبر بفلوس
جدا مش عايزين نتهرب مش عايزين نجرب مش
عايزين نكرر بس ما شاء الله 550 الف يورو
كل صباح شكرا جزيلا لك صحفي الرياضي محمد
حامد كان معنا فلسطين احنا صباح الفل يلا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات